Oh see ya  the dwarfs are a proud race who spend  the majority of their lives under the  mountains in glorious strongholds great  miners and Smith's their weapons are  among the most ornate and deadly in the  old world although short they are  powerfully built strong and accomplished  fighters preferring sharp-edged axes and  pulverizing hammers over the crude  stabbing weapons of inferior races our  artists and animators have really  enjoyed evoking that feeling of bundled  strength like a coiled spring unleashed  in battle a unit of dwarf or is is a  steadfast unit superior against basic  enemy infantry but equally capable of  bringing down more monstrous foes as  well dwarfs are far from cumbersome  brutes they are mighty warriors who  swings can gouge deep and crush goals in  a single deadly arc  subscribe to our YouTube channel and see  the dwarves in glorious battle in our  new trailer coming soon